well the county has given the green
light now to station casinos as the
company plans to move forward with plans
for a brand new property sasha loft is
here now with more on that property and
what it could look like
yes denise this is where the new casino
resort will be here along the 215 and
south durango while some in the area are
happy to see this change others say
they're not so sure
ready or not big changes are coming to
the southwest valley i think it's a
great idea not a fan those who live off
south durango in the 215 shared their
thoughts on durango a brand new casino
resort going up right in their backyard
station casinos got approval from the
clark county commission wednesday to
start construction in the 71 acre lot
the location as shown in these
renderings will feature 100 000 square
feet of casino entertainment and
convention space along with a 200 room
hotel tower it's nice to have something
on this side of town some like chris
cepeda are all for the idea
while others like sasha knox fear it
could bring safety issues for her kids
they like to ride their bikes around the
neighborhood and you know it's kind of
getting to a point where they can't
anymore while colin chapman is worried
about what this could mean for his
commute in the area the traffic is going
to be
insane and it's already bad enough over
here but no matter how they feel those
in this community say they'll try to
make the best of the move it is what it
is what can we do and embrace what it
means for the future of our local
economy if it puts people to work and
it's good for the community absolutely
station casino says construction is set
to start early next year and the
property is scheduled to open by late
2023 denise